[Music]
all right something that definitely
can't stay out of the news every single
time i look for articles and stuff like
that everything always constantly has to
mention something about honey oh no not
kanye and it's yay technically yeah
which is funny which is funny yeah
um but vaccines sounds like a filipino
lady to me
vaccine
francine
[ __ ] francine dude
boxing boxing
so to catch steve uh this is one of the
first shows where uh we get to hang out
with anthony after we've already been on
tour in australia
and so this is what going from ice to
view and anthony as a six-letter word
that starts with the f
um but then through the funny end yeah
but then through the tour oh this guy's
kind of cool and then on this tour this
is i mean on this show someone really
really bonded
and so me and jill were being managed by
geo at the time so anytime there's any
like transportation issues or show
issues we call it boom it's done like
tech rider whatever we need all that
stuff right
uh anthony
why do we have to do we have to leave
early or what was it we had to switch a
flight because some [ __ ] got delayed or
something got happened he didn't have
someone so he was just on the phone
that's his nice way of saying i managed
myself to manage himself over and over
and he just keeps getting the run around
and it was this filipino lady who
doesn't even know how to speak english
like at a call center you know one of
those call centers not even in america
and we just coined her francine because
literally the whole time we're in the
car like our [ __ ] got taken care of like
five minutes how long did it take you to
i was on hold for like three hours so
like our entire tour around the campus
was like stanford or something like that
like i'm like still on the phone talking
to francine who [ __ ] can't help me
yeah and like literally they had their
whole thing taken care of and even jill
is like yeah you just asked for this and
i got like a flight credits and then
they booked the next fight i'm like my
friend just got fight chris from you
guys i understand your frustration sir
you know what it sounded like she was
just reading off of the script and not
listening to you love it like the whole
protocol like did you unplug the modem
like no [ __ ] [ __ ] that's what i'm
calling you
i [ __ ] hate that [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
i did everything i could that's why i'm
calling and they ask you like you're
[ __ ] stupid yeah that's how they
asked you think i wanted to call you how
about that do you think i wanted to sit
on hold for 45 minutes before you pick
up no i tried to reset the router
already
believe it or not
i swear to god i did i love the series
my due diligence yeah but honestly i
learned a lot about the power of a geo
on that trip that's a balance where
francine comes from the the filipino
ladies didn't want to budge so speaking
of vaccines
like i said there's vaccines everywhere
i'm always randomly looking up stuff and
then i read this uh article title and i
i [ __ ] got intrigued it says
brothel offers people 30 minutes with
the lady of their choice in exchange for
a coven jab damn i already got my
[ __ ] vaccine though
i didn't know that was real i thought
that was a fake you need a booster get a
boosting oh where just go just gotta go
you just gotta go to vienna that's all
oh man that's australia
i didn't even know they had broncos
there that's crazy i got brothels
everywhere right legal i didn't know i
don't know about league i don't know
which places have it legal or not yeah
that's a good question amsterdam because
of the red light district yeah that one
amsterdam brothel and vienna is offering
customers 30 minutes with a lady of
their choice in exchange for getting the
coronavirus vaccine right so um
other places obviously have been
enticing people to get jabbed with like
free beer we've heard about things like
krispy kremes and donuts and stuff like
that even gym memberships are being
offered to people the longer you hold
out the better the deal gets yeah it
sounds like you're true we're about to
get houses today
damn it started with donuts that's
actually kind of true but what does the
brothel get in return for giving 30
minutes of time or money maybe how much
how much do you think they're getting
well the thing is um
ultimately some places that don't have
vaccinated depending on like city county
or state or country or whatever like if
you um some places have to shut down if
uh in terms of like being able to be
open for places if they have vaccine
mandates so let's say for example like
i'm a uh down the street brothel and i'm
not enforcing any concept of vaccine
maybe they're just going to shut my
business down oh i see or saying like
hey if you're not a vaccinated you can't
go into a a closed business
establishment like an actual building
that's the incentive yeah so the
incentive is not necessarily like what
are we giving the girls it's more like
if the girls even want work they might
need to give up 30 minutes to make sure
these people are vaccinated to make sure
they can continue because nobody's going
to come in there for 30 minutes and then
like
they'll probably buy at least another 30
right yeah maybe 30 minutes is like too
short you got to get the customer in the
door you know but wait you go in there
and you're not vast and then you [ __ ]
the chick and you don't have the
vaccination right you can you get it
after yeah what the [ __ ] get it during i
think i think you get the jab there you
get the jab and then you get to [ __ ] the
girl that's hilarious but even if that
happens it doesn't even make anyone not
protected right yeah right or the guy's
going to have flu-like symptoms while
he's that's what i'm saying
he's going to be like
chicks in the worst position of all yeah
dude clammy hands dude oh god you get a
vaccination and you get a chlamydias
come in with a vaccination leave with
the vaccines
that's a good deal man can i get there
get the flu vaccine
follow up 16 people have od'd on the
coronavirus vaccine at this brothel in
the life i guess i just get all of them
yeah dude get my mom's vaccine that's
crazy that's how it works do they give
it to you before you go in or after
they didn't say i'm not exactly sure of
the logistics of when you get
administered can they do anal does it
say that can you get a shot in our butt
you get in that chair is like [ __ ]
absurd
tell us
what kind of hats are they wearing when
they watch that's the best
can you ask the chief editor if they do
anal or not
what does that 30 minutes consist of 15
minutes of sweet talking 15 minutes of
saying bye
that's pretty good
that's pretty good right that's kind of
how it usually goes the venue which
builds itself as a sex star sauna club
said due to the pandemic we have
registered a 50 decrease in clients with
this initiative we hope that the number
of customers will rise again so the
manager of uh you know
one of these brothels like i said
um said that there was a way that the
brothel could help with austria's
vaccination problem after seeing an
overlap between the client base and the
unjab he said basically hold on
someone's knocking on the door
they said that they noticed that a
brothel could help with austria's
vaccination problem after seeing an
overlap between the client base and the
unjab and he said basically i was
looking at the statistics and i read
that we need like 70 to 75 for us to
reach herd immunity but we currently are
only at 63 percent and then i noticed in
the statistics that very many men very
many men with a migration background
virtually virtually refuse
vaccination or don't even know that you
can be vaccinated
so really the issue is men so the
whoremongers are the unvaccinated and
they're the ones spreading it so yeah
they're specifically targeting the
hormones yeah they literally said and
since we are actually reaching this
target group we decided to set up a
vaccination clinic at the broth so these
cats are like they come in they're like
we're talking about a vaccine for what
the hell's going on
what do you mean coveted what how are
you guys talking about he had no idea
he's talking about like hey you can't
have a lab dance without [ __ ] give it
to me yeah
it's like hey tldr tell me what the
[ __ ] going on quickly
compress
where the [ __ ] they've been just in
their room and
[ __ ] hookers every single week
brothel and home over and over don't all
these incentives make just the whole
vaccine topic feel really weird though
it's like the whole wheel that the whole
world is bending
like weirdly around this whole
conversation make it look like a rabbit
trap okay
like i think you know yeah so what
what's the incentive that gets you
vaccinated
what do you think they would give
it's like realistic i think ideally you
want to put out as much information
as possible no information and then you
just let me what is the bribe what is
the problem
what is the bribe my bribe was getting
my ass into hawaii because every single
time i go i got to pay 150 bucks for a
test that's a good deal that's a good
deal and then i spent over 500 bucks
already just doing covet tests to get to
hawaii jesus yeah have you heard of
europe's or or berlin's 2g rule for uh
for vaccines 2g what does that mean they
thought 5g gave people [ __ ] corona no
no i think they just i think they just
call it i think they just call it a 2g
coven 192g rule but basically um it was
a decision that just happened yesterday
actually um talking about how from
monday onwards only people who are
vaccinated against or who have recovered
from cover 19 will have access to
restaurants cinemas theaters museums or
galleries for example that's cool they
have natural immunity that's pretty cool
yeah that's what i don't understand is
like in other countries you can get the
immunity card once you've you know been
once you get covet or whatever and it
lasts for like three months are people
still are people still getting like
antibody tests
like pretty frequently i've seen that
because i don't really hear much about
it because my buddy was like
he is in trouble he's not really in
trouble but at his job he has to get the
vaccine
to be able to still work but he was
saying that like hey i got a vaccine
like i got coveted before
is there a way i could you know check my
natural immunity oh yeah let that pass
but
no they don't take it nothing nothing
but you know he also did get it in
last november
so i'm like hey man i don't know
different generation three months dude
that is a different generation
no new strains that's old-school [ __ ]
that's not even death
that's alpha right there's already been
like that's [ __ ] alpha
if you do get natural immunity it is
supposed to be more well adapted for
future variants though that's optimistic
so that's scientifically
what they said it's like a 0.001 chance
or some [ __ ]
it's crazy well i mean we could all go
to vienna for our next jk trip i think
we have to get the vaccine
you should get it
dude it's like it's like a german paris
yeah i like vienna without the filth
it's like german pairs without the you
call this filth i like it with the filth
i vote amsterdam
and i like after that too i've been it's
fun as [ __ ]
that was pretty awesome yo we could just
go to a [ __ ] coffee shop and like
smoke and then walk around yeah
and when the first time i i discovered a
space cake that's when i was studying
abroad uh in like 2007 and then i had a
spacecake which is just like a muffin
was my first time and then i went back
to my hostels when you had to pay like
18 euros for a hostel because you
couldn't afford anything there's like
six other beds there with lockers then i
lied on my bed now sinking forever right
and by the time i stopped singing i got
up and like four hours had passed damn
you just went backwards you were in a
big old [ __ ] tempur-pedic bed
yeah the
big the tempur-pedic bed went to china
it was really just a hostile that looked
dirtiest maybe you're just in a water
bed
it wasn't every hallucination it was
just real literal i was just sick
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you